كنا نسمع دائما ان الحياه تبدا في سن
الاربعين وكنا دائما نشعر بان السعاده
تلحقيقيه لم تترك بابن بعد ولكن ماذا عن
التعاسه
[موسيقى]
اسامه مر بتجارب عديده وبعدين بعد
الاربعين
دراسه جديده نسفت كل ما سببها باظهارها ان
الاشخاص في اواخر الاربعينيات من العمر
يصلون الى اعلى مستويات التعاسه وليس
السعاده فما السبب
[موسيقى]
بعد 40 سنه
اذا هذا راي الشارع اما التفسير العلمي
للشعور بالتعاسه في هذه المرحله العمريه
يعود الى ان الاشخاص والاهداف في الحياه
تتطور مع مرور الوقت
[موسيقى]
فبعكس العشرينيات في الاربعينيات من العمر
تساؤلات عده تشغل تفكير المرء حول اهداف
الحياه بعد هذا العمر وحول جدول استمرار
فيما هو عليه او تجربه شيء اخر كذلك
تساؤلات حول مكان العيش والامان المالي
وكان الدنيا التي يفترض ان تكون لطيفه
وخفيفه تكشر عن انيابها اكثر من قبل
هذه نصف الحقيقه فالنصف الاخر هو ان
كثيرين يشعرون في منتصف العمر بضروره
استعاده شبابهم والاستمتاع بالحياه رجاله
ونساء ولعلنا نكتشف في النهايه ان لكل
مرحله عمريه سعادتها الخاصه لصباح العربيه
عماد عداله عمان